[Music]
this is Steve Lacey you might not know
him yet but you probably know his music
he's part of the Bands new Internet he's
a producer with people like Jay Cole and
Kendrick Lamar and he just put out his
first solo music recently mother I'm
about to be crazy
[Laughter]
oh and he's 18
you might notice there's all this studio
equipment behind it Steve doesn't use
any of it well other than the swords I'm
gonna show you how I make music on my
phone I'll show you a little bit of the
process
Lisa records all of his music on his
phone he's used lots of apps before but
GarageBand is his favorite hey I started
off with the simple drum loop guitar
after the drums then he plugs his guitar
into his iPhone using an iRig cable
[Music]
melodye then he adds his vocals LaCie
would rather sing straight into the
iPhones like holding a pop filter and
getting right up close as he works he
just stacks the tracks one by one in
garage
I like to you know make wherever I am so
when I'm at home and my phone was my
first before I started going to that
Studios making beats on my phone like
just make it be something like the
absent like to drum kids and stuff but I
got this piece got the iRig I saw it you
can plug it into your iPhone and then I
was like oh the amps on here see what
cool guitar sounds I can get oh this
seems cool like nope Lacy's kind of a
big deal now he could use other
equipment but he likes making music on
his iPhone there's even something about
the sound that just feels very Steve he
calls his style plaid you know like the
shirt plaid is my John rrah
I found that out at a poster shopping
and I was in any Pendleton section as I
realized scuffling through the shirts
I'm like this kind of looks like how my
music sounds cuz if you listen to a
couple songs it might sound like there's
a lot going on but it doesn't clash you
know and plat that's you know it's a
it's a lot going on all goes together to
be one like pattern you know and that's
what you call a call
you
[Music]
Donna I love him